though Bob Barker did indeed retire from
hosting the prices right in 2007. it's
not actually the final time he appeared
on the show in fact it's not even the
last time he hosts it in 2009 Barker
popped up in a special guest appearance
walking out during a showcase to promote
his book Priceless Memories emerging to
a thunderous Applause he shook hands
with his replacement Drew Carey before
gifting a copy of his book to every
member of the audience and announcing
that all profits from the sale of the
book would go to his non-profit DJ and T
Foundation six years later as part of
the show's annual April Fool's tradition
The Price is Right introduced Drew Carey
only for Barker himself to come out on
stage I have never had a welcome like
that Barker at age 92 may have been a
little slower than fans were used to
seeing him but he was as sharp as ever
in his final hosting gig handling the
first bid and pricing game before
handing the Reigns back over to Kerry